so as you guys know I'm a I'm a big
Candace Owens fans I I love Candace
Owens I remember a couple years ago um
when black lives matter was like in full
swing she was just going crazy on
Twitter and I really wasn't that like
into media at that point like I was I
think I was selling copiers at this time
um it was like around the George Floyd
thing but she got so much media hate oh
my gosh this poor woman and she was
right oh my gosh she was so right like
BLM was a complete scam just like she
said
and now Candace Owens is going on it's
really interesting to see her in like
the red pill space a bit because I think
she's kind of I think she's kind of red
pill so Candace Owens went on the
whatever podcast with a bunch of only
fans chicks and yeah let's let's pull
these clips well thoughts on the
passport Pro movement of men leaving
America for better wives abroad yes
quality women other places like I
Married an Englishman I'm I think
America passport not a bro a passport
passport says there you go uh yeah I
think that America has really lowered
the cultural standards for women more
than any and you don't see this kind of
even the way women dress in America
compared to England fascinates me and so
yeah I I think find a wife do what you
gotta do but also don't discount the
South because there are so many good
women in the south in America come to
Tennessee they're wonderful
oh no women dress just like Americans
here oh let's not
sorry she she married a very wealthy
English guy so maybe she's just on like
the the average English chick I promise
you I promise you is not much better
than the Americans I mean
maybe like five percent ten percent but
if you look at the average age of first
marriage it's still it's it's more
modern than the US it's 31 here I think
it's 30 in the U.S
yeah but I will say seeing her on the
whatever podcast was so funny I support
the passport Bros too I really think as
women what we should do is ask well why
are they going overseas and try to learn
you know I mean let's let's be honest
America us American women
really have a leg down you know a lot of
the women overseas were actually sort of
raised to be wives but the women here in
the UK and the U.S really were not
raised at all to be wives like not even
not even slightly so I just say you know
maybe get a lesson